[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 am
a romero sala en el estudio mar esto es
algo generalizado digamos que me pasa
mucho porque desde la pandemia comí 19
parece que estamos todo el tiempo en
alerta digamos con esta nueva vídeo la
del mono también la detección del virus
de la polio en londres mejor dicho
cualquier enfermedad que aparezca por
vieja que sea pues nos alarmamos de una
manera que antes no lo hacíamos y
también por ejemplo la gripe aviar que
cada dos por tres hay nuevas alertas no
te entiendo creo que como tú raúl los
somos muchos los que nos sentimos así y
no vamos a ser nosotros los que digamos
que hablar de salud o de enfermedades es
malo porque precisamente esto es lo que
hacemos en esta sección pero es verdad
que es bueno que evaluemos o hablemos
bien de qué está pasando si realmente es
un fenómeno epidemiológico o es una cosa
más pues de atención mediática que le
estamos poniendo ahora entonces bueno
para resolver todo esto estamos con
oscar franco doctor epidemiólogo y
profesor de salud pública la universidad
de berna que hoy nos atiende desde
berlín en alemania doctor realmente los
virus podemos decir que están fuera de
control y las bacterias o es que lo que
sucede es que estamos prestando más
atención por culpa de la pandemia de
cobain 19
yo creo que antes que todo debemos
darnos cuenta que realmente los virus y
las bacterias nunca han estado realmente
bajo control estamos en un proceso
evolutivo de una competición de expertos
y yo creo que lo que estamos viendo
ahora es una combinación de la paranoia
así de la mayor alarma que hemos vivido
durante el 19 pero al mismo tiempo
estamos siendo víctimas de nuestro
propio éxito vemos como en la segunda
mitad del siglo 20 los programas de
vacunación fueron muy exitosos hicieron
enfermedades que eran comunes como como
la polio que se volvieran raras y eso ha
hecho que hemos bajado la guardia y
muchas personas no se están vacunando
entonces es una combinación sí de
atención sí de falta de cuidado y por
otro lado también los virus que
continúan matando o la torre saludo muy
buen día le pregunto si toda esta
atención a la salud haya estos brotes es
es positiva o negativa que considera
usted
una atención exagerada es negativa
porque genera la 'armada' lo que genera
nerviosismo intranquilidad de la
población creo que la atención se tiene
que mantener porque ayuda a informar y
si algo que hemos visto durante la
pandemia es que es esencial el acceso a
la información la información que sea
adecuada bien informada y objetiva
entonces yo creo que debemos utilizar la
oportunidad que estamos viviendo con el
kobe para crear programas de información
como este para poder llevar a la informe
la información a la población en general
pero por ejemplo un ejemplo que se nos
ocurría es el tema de que se detectó un
brote de cólera en españa'
al menos así lo anunciaron y luego
cuando lo revisaron vieron que a pesar
de ser la misma bacteria pues no era la
enfermedad que había provocado no era un
nuevo caso de cólera en españa- pero
digamos que en ese punto el mal ya está
hecho ya hemos corrido demasiado
si es que vamos muy aceleradamente y
quizás algunos medios buscando más
atención buscando ver más vistas en
youtube por ventas y no realmente
enfocándonos en la información por eso
es fundamental trabajar en equipos
científicos y periodistas para poder
poner dentro de contexto y entender la
gravedad del asunto antes de levantar la
alarma y de asustar a la población
también le pregunto había estado
hablando de pues casas de vacunación que
han bajado a raíz de la pandemia por
ejemplo del apoyo pero son muchas otras
enfermedades que también venimos
recordando aquí en el programa esto
hasta qué punto también está influyendo
a que aparezcan nuevas enfermedades u
otras actividades humanas hemos hablado
de la deforestación de la minería ilegal
como de actividades que también nos
ponen más en riesgo para futuras
pandemias o resurgimiento de
enfermedades esto hasta qué punto
realmente está pasando y nos va a abrir
la puerta a un nuevo a una nueva etapa
digamos de enfermedades
por supuesto esto está jugando un papel
muy importante vamos cada vez invadiendo
más los ecosistemas destruyendo la
biodiversidad y lo que estamos haciendo
es entrando en contacto con especies con
virus con patógenos con los que
normalmente no tendríamos contacto
adicionalmente estamos destruyendo el
planeta esto ha llevado a la aceleración
del cambio climático y el cambio
climático también va a cambiar la
distribución geográfica de los virus de
los patógenos y como estos afectan a la
población mundial entonces es una
combinación de factores que también
incluye el medio ambiente en la forma
como estamos tratando al planeta
doctores le quiero preguntar entonces
mejor pedir su recomendación para cómo
podemos contribuir a informar sin
generar la alarma desde los medios de
comunicación
creo que es esencial que trabajemos en
equipo como lo estamos haciendo aquí en
este programa los periodistas que tengan
un mejor entrenamiento en ciencia los
científicos que tengan una mejor
entrenamiento en comunicaciones y
nosotros trabajar en equipo para poder
llevar la información de manera más
adecuada objetiva e informada a la
población general bueno también yo
quiero agregar más doctor no sé si
ustedes concuerdan conmigo que no
dejarse llevar tampoco por la
desinformación que circula también
muchas veces por redes sociales por
mensajería instantánea como por ejemplo
por whatsapp y como le decía usted
también doctor puedes confiar se digamos
a medios de comunicación serios y
responsables para realmente tener un
contexto y estar bien informados de lo
que está sucediendo y pues no generar
esta alarma y en el caso de que las
personas no consuman o no quieran ver un
medio de comunicación sea la razón que
sea puedes ir a las fuentes oficiales
como por ejemplo en este caso de salud a
la organización mundial de la salud a la
organización panamericana de la salud
doctor marc sino por supuesto y también
agregar el peligro que a veces suponen
las redes sociales también una gran
herramienta
y tener en cuenta que también hay muchos
estudios científicos que se retuitean a
veces ampliamente cuando no tienen una
base científica entonces podemos en los
próximos programas de artix también para
entender cómo leer cómo procesar esta
información
como siempre mar y autor o muchísimas
gracias por este espacio de salud de
france 24
informando con responsabilidad de la
mano de los expertos como se team
también el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
nosotros ahora pasamos a saludar a
nuestra segunda mitad del día